gathered to remember the life and work
of poet and Soldier Maxim ksof killed in
action just a few weeks earlier known
simply to his friends and fans by his
nickname
Dary he was such a bright person who is
not with us anymore but you can feel his
soul and spirit is still with us to give
inspiration to others this exhibition
documenting life on the front line was
already being planned when he was killed
some of the photos left without captions
that he never got to write effectively
his last postumus and incomplete
work through his photographs he showed
us his journey his poetry is that of a
person who spent years at War while
still preserving his Humanity Dary joins
a growing list of prominent artists and
writers killed in this war writer
Victoria amalina who died from injury
sustained in a rocket attack on this
restaurant in katos last summer poet and
novelist ehor misak was serving as a
paramedic when he was killed last year
and children's author vadir valeno who
was abducted from his occupied Village
at the start of the war and whose
remains were later discovered at a mass
burial site in Ukraine's centuries long
struggle to establish a distinctive
national identity literature has always
played a significant role and never more
so since Russia's fullscale Invasion
nearly 2 years ago that threatened the
country's very existence that threat has
helped drive a resurgent cultural
interest that's a positive trend with
people now more interested more
thoughtful more conscious about
Ukrainian
culture on stage dar's father reading
the words his son left behind Rob
McBride elazer
ke make sure to subscribe to our channel
to get the latest news from Al jazer